if i give you results to your company i  get money in exchange now of course  eventually you're gonna need money to  invest into a company all the other  things you need to do start a business i  totally get it but as far as the same  goes you need money to make money  there's many different ways people  exchange  for money and most of it doesn't have to  do with money if a person goes to a  company making a hundred thousand  dollars or fifty thousand dollars a half  a million dollars or do they go in and  say you know what  before i give you two hundred thousand  all your salary i need you to give me a  hundred thousand dollars is that kind of  what happens then what happens they  didn't give them money to get money  right no it's skills time effort  specialized skill set that'll also get  you the money then if you want to start  your business yes you do need to kind of  figure out a way to go raise money